bienvenue dans parlement hebdo votre
rendez vous d'info du week-end retour
sur les temps forts qui ont marqué la
semaine politique une semaine
particulièrement dense entre le fiasco
du passage à paris de la flamme
olympique la motion de censure
l'examen du projet de loi ogm et la
sphère nkm comprenez nathalie kosciusko
morizet sans oublier bien sûr la
polémique autour de la carte de famille
nombreuse en clair une rude semaine et
peut-être tout particulièrement pour
l'ump et c'est pourquoi perrine notre
invité tombe à pic
oui l'homme qui tombe à pic cette
semaine c'est dominique paillé
conseiller de nicolas sarkozy à l'elysée
est nouveau porte parole de l'ump avec
cette réorganisation du parti après la
débâcle des élections alors donc on va
revenir ensemble sur toute l'actualité
de cette semaine que vient de résumer
brillamment emilie un peu la semaine de
tous les cafouillages à droite ce qui
rend d'autant plus indispensable une
qualification par nicolas sarkozy on
attend peut-être une intervention
télévisée pour la semaine du 21 avril on
en reparlera plus tard mais je vous
propose ce type d'aborder la semaine
bien sûr par la journée de lundi et ce
devait être une fête et c'est devenu le
chemin de croix de l'olympisme lundi la
traversée de paris de la flamme
olympique a tourné au fiasco
malgré une solide escorte policière à
plusieurs reprises le relais a été
interrompue
la flamme mis à l'abri dans un bus est
un terreau allumé à plusieurs reprises
et les écarts 10 a suivi pour nous ce
parcours chaotique en plein paris midi
sous la tour eiffel la flamme olympique
s'apprête à partir pour un tour de paris
sous haute protection policière
c'est stéphane diagana l'ex champion
d'athlétisme qui est le premier à faire
le relais dans la foule
la tension monte
le cortège doit s'arrêter à plusieurs
reprises à chaque fois des incidents
sont signalés
mais jean claude killy ne regrette pas
le choix du comité olympique il y avait
une décision à prendre à ce moment là le
sait où elle a pris je crois de manière
magnifique
on attribuera les jeux
franchir à la chute au même moment au
trocadéro des militants des droits de
l'homme se mobilise plusieurs centaines
de personnes réunies pour alerter sur la
situation au tibet et là aussi la police
à des directives les la police est là
nous n'avons pas le droit de passer nous
n'avons pas le droit de rentrer chez
nous nous n'avons pas le droit de
prendre tout ça rime ton fils que le
moindre le moindre truc rebelles à la
manifestation pour le tibet c'est
absolument scandaleux
voilà ces personnalités politiques de
droite de gauche des artistes aussi ce
relais à la tribune pour demander le
boycott des jeux olympiques devant moi
ce que j'ai c'est que aujourd'hui les
gens ne lui dise non parce que c'est la
vérité mais que malheureusement la
formation et c'est la solution parce que
un tel déploiement de forces de l'ordre
protéger la flamme qui qui en fait le le
le symbole de la pureté qui doit être le
symbole de l'olympisme c'est à dire de
la fraternité entre les peuples de la
fraternité entre la jeunesse du monde
et bien c'est pas digne de notre pays
c'est pas digne de la france c'est pas
digne de l'est du pays des droits de
l'homme à 14h on murmure que la flamme a
été éteinte plus tard on apprendra
qu'elle a été mise en sécurité dans un
bus ce soir l'organisation a jeté l
éponge des derniers relais ont été
annulés la flamme a pris le bus pour
rejoindre son point d'arrivée au stade
charléty de toute façon avec au moins
huit interpellations dans la journée le
passage de la flamme
aujourd'hui c'était tout sauf la fête
elle est toujours lundi après pékin
direction gandrange en moselle et les
575 postes supprimés ces derniers jours
par le groupe arcelormittal
il s'agit vous savez du site sur lequel
le président sarkozy s'était rendu début
février promettant l'aide de l'état pour
maintenir le site en activité
belle occasion aujourd'hui pour la
gauche de dénoncer un président qui ne
tient pas ses promesses
un président digne héritier de
supermenteur ça c'est signé de la
députée ps aurélie filippetti lundi
l'elysée et le groupe ont donc tenté de
sauver la face des syndicalistes du site
ont même été reçus faubourg saint-honoré
et arcelormittal de faire de nouvelles
propositions tout de suite le rappel des
faits avec flora sauvage c'était le 4
février à l'usiné de gandrange en
moselle nicolas sarkozy s'engage à ne
pas laisser tomber les salariés
d'arcelormittal menacés de perdre leur
emploi les syndicats des salariés
étaient reçus cet après midi à l'elysée
ils sont déçus longueur pour le chef de
l'état n'a pas tenu ses promesses
aujourd'hui libre
il reconnaît que en allant n'a pas pu
tenir ses promesses
il a joué avec nous parce qu'une agence
a quand même suscité
plus de d'espoir et d'espérance dans la
tête tout de toute une vallée
tc mission mission accomplie et 50%
le groupe arcelormittal a confirmé la
suppression de 575 emplois
aujourd'hui il a annoncé un
investissement de 30 millions d'euros et
la création de 124 postes
pour les syndicats ce n'est pas
suffisant l'état en ce qui concerne la
politique industrielle ne peut rien
faire sur une décision d'un dada d'un
industriel est en l'occurrence un
industriel international
donc c'est un message quand même qui
nous inquiète en ce qui concerne la cgt
est ce que la france aujourd'hui et va
encore quoi avoir une politique
industrielle fort prochaine étape le 14
avril date à laquelle est fixée la
première réunion pour mettre en oeuvre
le plan social par dominique paillé
peut-être qu'on peut dire que c'était là
le premier cafouillage de la semaine
avec ses annonces d'abord vendredi
dernier de suppressions de postes et
puis finalement revirement annonce de
créations de postes est ce que tout ça
de toute façon ne va pas accréditer
encore un peu plus l'idée que nicolas
sarkozy n'a pas beaucoup de suite dans
les idées précisément des cantons veut
être un détracteur de nicolas sarkozy on
peut travestir une réalité et la ranger
à sa couleur et non l'affairé
arcelormittal n'est pas terminée en tout
cas la sphère de gandrange les
propositions qui ont été faites lundi
sont des propositions qui permettent de
ne laisser sur le bord du chemin aucun
des employés de l'entreprise actuelle il
y à des emplois créés qui permettront de
reconvertir ceux qui ne pourront pas
rester dans leur poste
il y a également des engagements pris
pour dans la région essayer de voir
comment régler un certain nombre de cas
individuels sur d'autres entreprises
il y est enfin il y a qu'à sens pas très
convaincu que cette proposition pour
l'instant les syndicats sont dubitatifs
encore une fois ils sont dans leur rôle
ils sont là pour maintenir la pression
chacun le comprend bien et tour essayer
le faire en sorte que les engagements
soient tenus des premières repreneur
pour le site il aurait arraché aux
syndicalistes
elle n'en a pas trouvé c'est un peu un
constat d'échec le président à quick a
d'abord promis qu'il n'y aurait pas de
pertes d'emplois sur le secteur il y a
à la suite de cette réunion de lundi un
certain nombre de choses qui ont été
actés à la fois des créations nouvelles
dans des domaines d'activité qui restent
dans la sidérurgie
et que donc l'engagement de mittal des
perspectives de création à moyen terme
de structures qui permettront de
reconvertir toujours sur les métiers qui
gravitent autour de la sidérurgie un
certain nombre de personnels si c'était
nécessaire et on fait un engagement
regarder dans les entreprises alentour
comment faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
plus personne qui restent sans emploi à
l'issue du processus
pas question d'investir des fonds
publics alors écoutez il n'y avait pas
de repreneur
le président de la république l'a dit il
faut lui reconnaître l'honnêteté de
mettre les cartes sur la table
il s'est battu il n'a pas trouvé de
repreneur pour autant il n'y aura pas de
casse sociale si vous me permettez cette
expression
allez on continue cette journée de lundi
avec une question autour de l'udf
peut-elle renaître de ses cendres c'est
en tout cas le souhait de jean arthuis
déçu par le modem le week-end dernier le
sénateur centriste a claqué la porte du
parti de françois bayrou dont il juge la
politique illisible mais l'udf
existe-t-elle encore à qui appartiennent
ces statues et ses locaux l'anc est
donné que la béart l'udf est elle encore
en vie statutairement le modem l'a
remplacé depuis le congrès fondateur de
décembre dernier mais légalement elle
subsiste encore comme l'une des
composantes du mouvement démocrate
composantes que le sénateur jean arthuis
aimerait voir revenir sur le devant de
la scène politique comme d'autres
parlementaires d'ailleurs qui avait déjà
quitté françois bayrou pour la majorité
présidentielle nouveau centre s'ils
pouvaient changer de nom et s'appeler
des entrepreneurs ça c'est évident que
c'est le rêve de chacun d'entre nous
est-ce que j'aurais dû m'en sers aussi
pro moment de l'impression que non en
fait nous serons là brûlée à nouveau
centre n'est que l'udf reconstituer sauf
cas n'a pas le nom puisque je dis quoi
ne peux pas le contrôler
autre problème les locaux du modem à
paris rue de l'université
si l'udf retrouve une autonomie
politique elle pourrait en réclamer
restitution d'après jean arthuis ses
locaux appartiennent à l'udf
le sénateur de la mayenne étudierait
déjà les moyens juridiques pour régler
la question
surfer veut lancer ouvrir le débat
hélas sa manière d'entrer dans le débat
il ya d'abord un problème de fond par
une politique de fond en france qui est
celui de savoir si comme en structure
une famille centriste indépendante et
forte ça c'est la question de fond
parlons la question de fond ont connu
entre eux par des prêts immobiliers au
bord d'autres d'autres entrées pour
cette un peu anecdotique
à l'initiative de françois bayrou un
comité directeur de l'udf se réunira le
16 avril
ce comité regroupe une vingtaine de
personnes pour veiller aux intérêts
juridiques matériels et moraux de l'udf
c'est le moment et on reviendra un peu
plus tard dans la semaine assure
justement l'avenir du centre également
dominique paillé sur une note qui vous a
été attribué à tort ou à raison on verra
sur l'avenir de françois bayrou est ce
qu'il reste l'homme à abattre ou non à
droite on en reparlera un peu plus tard
tout il vous propose de regarder la
journée de mardi
mardi affluence des grands jours à
l'assemblée nationale pour la première
motion de censure du quinquennat sarkozy
ciblées sur l'atlantisme présumé de la
politique étrangère du gouvernement le
texte rédigé par les socialistes a sans
surprise été rejetée
la gauche a fait le plein de ses voix
mais elle a échoué en revanche dans sa
stratégie de rallier la droite
souverainiste et puis c'est un françois
fillon très en verve qu'on a pu entendre
ce jour là dans l'hémicycle tout de
suite retour sur cette journée de
censure avec anaïs booba tian le parti
socialiste a décidé de censurer le
gouvernement
motif sa position en afghanistan nicolas
sarkozy aurait des ambitions atlantiste
l'opposition ne manquait pas de raisons
pour mettre en cause aujourd'hui la
responsabilité de votre gouvernement
et pourtant nous avons voulu placer
notre débat d'aujourd'hui de censure sur
les graves décisions que le président de
la république vient de prendre à
l'occasion du sommet de l'otan à
bucarest
françois hollande aurait préféré élargir
le débat et en profiter pour sanctionner
le gouvernement
man sur sa politique économique mais
c'est finalement laurent fabius qui a eu
gain de cause
l'ancien premier ministre a réussi à
rallier tous les courants du parti
socialiste la question centrale pour les
français c'est pouvoir d'achat donc
disait françois hollande et quelques
autres parlant du pouvoir d'achat et
d'autres dont laurent fabius 10 et
concentrons nous sur ce qui est dans
l'actualité c'est à dire l'otan et
l'afghanistan bon moi je trouve que
c'est une position raisonnable attaquer
le gouvernement sur sa politique
extérieure reste un pari risqué dans son
discours françois fillon a donné une
leçon de géopolitique à la gauche en
pointant ses incohérences en matière de
politique internationale
il cite sous laurent fabius lionel
jospin et surtout françois mitterrand
lorsqu'il approuva en 1983 et ceci fort
légitimement l'installation des fusées
américaines père chine 2 cela me va lui
écrit-il d'être accusé d'atlantisme
sous-entendu de soumission au dessin de
monsieur reagan l'atlantisme comme péché
ajoutait-il
voilà tartuffes qui se confesse les
députés socialistes ont perdu la face la
motion de censure devait offrir une
tribune à l'opposition c'est finalement
la majorité qui en a profité
à la sortie de l'hémicycle dans les
couloirs du palais bourbon
la déception chez des socialistes était
palpable nous avons peut-être pour faire
au premier ministre des bateaux pour
nous faire-part nous aurions
restés sur les sujets économiques
et sociaux vous savez une motion de
censure des socialistes attendent
toujours bien parce que c'est une
excellente occasion pour nous de mettre
les pieds dans le plat de tordre le cou
à toute cette désinformation auquel se
livrent les socialistes et puis de
mettre de les mettre devant leurs
contradictions
pari manqué donc pour les socialistes
dernière solution pour eux attaqué la
politique du gouvernement
mais cette fois sur les questions
économiques et notamment sur le pouvoir
d'achat
dominique paillé vous qui on le sait est
un fin stratège est ce que vous pensez
qu effectivement la gauche a peut-être
commis une erreur tactique en ciblant sa
première motion de censure sur ce sujet
de la politique étrangère et pas sur le
bilan économique et social du
gouvernement la soirée elle d'ailleurs
était peut-être plus difficile pour la
majorité
écoutez je observe que vos commentaires
sont très objectif
et quand on voit la tête de ceux qui
sortent à gauche de l'hémicycle
on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement ça a été
une journée difficile pour le parti
socialiste
pourquoi parce que sur sept ce plan de
la politique internationale il n'y a
rien à reprocher à nicolas sarkozy il
avait annoncé clairement la couleur
il avait annoncé clairement la couleur
pour ce qui le concernait il y aura de
la droite de la défense
il avait annoncé clairement la couleur
pour le passage houleux réintégration du
commandement intégré de l'otan
dans l'hypothèse dans sa campagne colas
sarkozy avait dit que la france n'avait
pas vocation à pérenniser quoi sa
présence en afghanistan les troupes à
quoi est ce qu'on voyait aujourd'hui 700
soldats complémentaire est
contradictoire avec ce qu'il a dit sa
vocation est de mal hier l'ong
gloire éternelle mais pour autant nous
ne pouvons pas quitter un pays dans
lequel nous sommes solidaires de nos
alliés européens avant que le travail
était et convenablement fait et le
travail convenablement fait s'est
installée d'une manière pérenne le
gouvernement démocratique d'afghanistan
de karzaï dans sa capacité à assurer la
défense de son propre territoire
et deuxièmement chasse et autant que
faire se peut et les arrêter les
talibans qui sont commencées le berceau
est internationaux de france pas le côté
un peu gaulois des français d'opinion
publique quand il entend que vous mettez
fin à des principes gaulliste à
l'autonomie française
vous des français a donné une leçon je
reprends les propres termes du
commentaire de géostratégie
internationale nous sommes depuis 93 95
dans toutes les opérations militaires de
l'otan tout
pas une seule exception nous sommes
également aux commandes des opérations
militaires de l'otan dans un certain non
sur un certain nombre de théâtres
d'opération avec l'accord des amériques
ce que dit nicolas sarkozy c'est qu'il
faut tirer de cette situation des
conclusions simple on rentre à
l'intérieur du commandement intégré avec
une défense européenne beaucoup plus
intégrée elle même et on pèsera
davantage dans les décisions
stratégiques et pour autant nous
garderons notre indépendance parce que
notre force de frappe nucléaire ne sera
pas concernée par cette intégration
allez on change de sujet avec maintenant
ce projet pour paris et sa proche
banlieue un projet qui se veut une
rupture le sénateur philippe dallier a
présenté mardi son plan pour le grand
paris il prévoit notamment la fusion
entre la capitale les quatre
départements de la petite couronne
mais ces propositions sont loin de faire
l'unanimité y compris à droite nicolas
béart quatre départements supprimer la
proposition est de taille dans le grand
paris de philippe dallier les
départements de la petite couronne
pourrait disparaître
pour le sénateur de la seine-saint-denis
cet échelon supra départementale
permettraient une mutualisation efficace
des politiques dans nombre de domaines
il ya une cohérence entre les problèmes
qui sont à issy les moulineaux à neuilly
à yvré et et à paris intra muros ce sont
les mêmes problèmes sur la pollution sur
la circulation sur le logement
beaucoup de problèmes sont communs à un
traitement des déchets traitement de
l'eau donc c est le problème une grande
métropole philippe dallier dénonce un
mille feuille institutionnel inefficace
et coûteux communes intercommunalités
départements régions et état il condamne
une multiplicité d'interlocuteurs qui se
court circuitent les uns les autres
ce n'est pourtant pas l'avis des
conseillers généraux je pense que si on
devait créer une
stance technocratique on éloignerait
encore plus les lieux de pouvoir des
citoyens et je pense que ça ça serait
inefficace alors bien sûr que les
coopérations sont nécessaires et
incontournables mais encore une fois
nous n'avons pas besoin de faire
disparaître les départements pour
avancer dans cette dans cette volonté le
rapport divise au sein même de la
majorité le secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement roger
karoutchi s'insurge contre cet appel à
décapiter les conseils généraux à la
rascasse selon vous c'est une bonne
proposition peut parier ce qui de
couronnes
c'est une contribution et je tiens cette
rencontre et je cite je tiens à saluer
le travail de ce sénateur c'est une
contribution il y en aura d'autres comme
vous l'avez remarqué nicolas sarkozy a
donné la charge de réfléchir à un projet
dans la concertation au nouveau
secrétaire d'état christian blanc et
donc pour ma part je pense que l'heure
n'est pas venue de dire que telle ou
telle solution est d'ores et déjà ça va
être compliqué à gérer puisque les
ambitions des uns et des autres qui se
réveille avec archie légaux c'est
évident que ça ne sera pas simple
d'abord au delà des ambitions
personnelles que vous pouvez souligné
parce que les problèmes sont complexes
et qu' on ne peut pas balayer d'un
revers de main un certain nombre
d'années d'existence de structures qui
sont intervenus dans deux domaines de
compétences qui étaient les leurs avec
souvent beaucoup d'efficacité alors on
attendra donc les propositions de
christian blanc secrétaire d'état chargé
du grand silence sera récompensé
on va passer maintenant j à la journée
de mercredi avec cette cacophonie
gouvernementale autour de la sphère nkm
privé de questions au gouvernement et
privées de voyages gouvernementale au
japon elle est la punition la sanction
de nkm nathalie kosciusko morizet la
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie jugé
coupable d'avoir exprimé au grand jour
son sentiment d'isolement à l'occasion
de l'examen du projet de loi sur les ogm
une chose est sûre en tout cas la faire
nkm a révélé au grand jour les
dissensions qui existent à droite entre
les pro et les anti et cultures
transgéniques au final le texte a
d'ailleurs été votée à une très courte
majorité tout de suite le rappel des
faits avec céline bittner ils sont tous
là les membres du gouvernement pour la
traditionnelle séance de questions
d'actualité tous enfin presque nathalie
kosciusko morizet est aux abonnés
absents
la secrétaire d'état prive également du
vote du texte sur les ogm
françois fillon lui même lui a demandé
de ne pas venir à l'assemblée nationale
voilà ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres
cet article du monde nathalie kosciusko
morizet dénonçant concours de lâcheté et
d'inélégance notamment de jean françois
copé et de jean louis borloo
hier déjà l attaque et nommément le
président du groupe ump à l'assemblée
nationale on voit ce que je vois c'est
qu'il ya une tentative de dérivation de
la part de certains responsables du coup
notamment la part de son président jean
françois copé qui porte une lourde
responsabilité dans la façon dont les
débats soient engagées des propos qui ne
passe pas dans les rangs de la majorité
les propos de m libre
démont attristé d'abord à titre
personnel et puis ensuite parce que
qu'il personnel c'est une chose mais
enfin aussi moma beaucoup de patrice
m'ont beaucoup attristé pour l'ensemble
de mes amis députés parce que nous
essayons de faire notre travail le mieux
possible
une réunion urgente du groupe ump donc
organisé françois fillon demande des
excuses publiques de la secrétaire
d'état tout fini par s'exécuter
écoutez s'est excusé l'incident est clos
et avec le temps la peine s'atténuera
voilà un incident clôt pas tout à fait
pour certains députés ump qui ont
demandé la démission de la secrétaire
d'état
je trouve l'acte de nathalie kosciusko
morizet assez grave pour ma part parce
que je considère que ce n'est pas un
dérapage c'est un acte de sa part tout à
fait rationnelle elle jouait démocratie
d'opinion contre le parlement
finalement nathalie kosciusko morizet a
pu trouver du soutien dans les rangs de
l'opposition
à gauche on salue sa liberté de parole
on lui a demandé des excuses publiques
sous la force en dessinant toutes les
conséquences en seraient tirées çà veut
dire qu'on lui demande de démissionner
du gouvernement
je crois que c'est une attitude qui en
démocratie n'est pas acceptable
il est normal que dans un gouvernement
tous les ministres ne soit pas à la
botte forcément du premier ministre une
crise gouvernementale qui va laisser des
traces
après sa promotion par nicolas sarkozy
au sein de l'ump nathalie kosciusko
morizet est sanctionné par françois
fillon
elle est privée de voyage au japon avec
le premier ministre
mais malgré cette affaire nathalie
kosciusko morizet a été confirmé dans
ses nouvelles fonctions de secrétaire
générale adjointe à l'ump
pour jean pierre raffarin la secrétaire
d'état a commis une faute mais pas de
quoi non plus exiger sa démission
écoutez le nathalie kosciusko est une
fille très intelligente c'est un
ministre de qualité il se trouve que la
halle a dérapé disons les choses très
clairement elle voulait passer au vert
est passé au rouge on lui enlève
quelques points mais il faut prendre
levé le permis c'est un dérapage
il est comme ça cette excuse et je pense
que c'est important
il est clair que il ya eu du désordre
parlement à l'assemblée nationale sur ce
sujet et la sagesse sénatoriales la
semaine prochaine remettra ce texte dans
le bon sens alors remettre ce texte dans
le bon sens ça veut dire quoi dominique
paillé que tout ce qui avait l'air
effectivement d'avoir été ajoutées à
l'assemblée qui allaient dans le sens du
grenelle de l'environnement va de
nouveau être détricoter ce qui va dans
le sens du grenelle environnement c'est
la proposition et les arbitrages du
gouvernement ni plus ni moins donc
remettre remettre le texte dans le bon
sens c'est se rapprocher le plus
possible du texte que le gouvernement
avait soumis à l'assemblée nationale et
donc nous allons voir ce qu'il va
advenir du texte au sénat
ce que je crois c'est que cette affaire
a été effectivement monté en épingle
nathalie kosciusko morizet ce n'est pas
par qui mais ce n était dans le chaudron
qu'est l'assemblée nationale et avec
l'écho journalistique qui est donné aux
événements se déroulent
je crois que on a fait d'un mouvement
d'humeur une affaire d'état ne risquons
pas en vouloir à bxl comme quelqu'un qui
est passionnant voilà cette année en
vouloir d'être associé à la cause dans
sa personne ne lui reproche ce que je
peux simplement dire il ya des mots qui
sont ressenties comme des injures et
qu'à ce titre là ils n'ont pas à être
prononcée elle s'est excusée
dont acte pour moi l'affairé est close
pour autant quelle que soit vos
sentiments respectifs respecter aussi
ceux qui estiment que le progrès dit
avoir droit de cité dans notre pays et
qui à ce titre la défendent la culture
encadré de gm pour que nous ne prenions
pas de retard sur la scène
internationale dans un domaine nous
avons été longtemps très performant qui
va défendre au sénat pour la seconde
lecture la semaine prochaine le texte
dans l'hémicycle qu'est ce que ça sera
nathalie kosciusko morizet ou jean louis
borloo on l'a très peu vu que ce soit au
sénat
dans les églises pour des shows avec un
titre personnel que les deux soient dans
l'hémicycle à ce moment là il n'y a
aucune raison que nathalie kosciusko
morizet n'y soit pas il n'y a aucune
raison que jean-louis borloo ne soit pas
à ses côtés pour défendre ce texte ce
sera la meilleure démonstration de
l'unité et de la cohérence du globe
dernière question il ya vraiment une
lisibilité de l'action gouvernementale
en matière environnementale après cette
affaire il n'ya pas quand même un
décalage entre les grandes ambitions
annoncées du grenelle de l'environnement
et puis ce à quoi on assiste aujourd'hui
passé d'où je crois qu'il ya une
cohérence totale et ce projet de texte
n'est que la transposition d'une
directive européenne qui point par point
dans ce que le gouvernement avait
demandé respecter le grenelle de
l'environnement
basta cosi bouger plus pour gagner plus
c'est le principe du texte sur la
mobilité des fonctionnaires adopté
mercredi en conseil des ministres ils
sont seulement 5% à changer de poste
aujourd'hui alors pour les inciter à
bouger le gouvernement va prendre seize
mesures est proposé notamment un pécule
de départ c'est-à-dire une aide
financière pour ceux qui quittent la
fonction publique avec un projet
professionnel les explications des les
écarts n'y ai proposé un pécule jusqu'à
2 ans de salaire pour les fonctionnaires
qui voudrait intégrer le privé à
condition qu'il présente un projet
sérieux
la mesure est mise en avant comme un
vrai progrès mais selon le ministère des
finances seulement 10 % des
fonctionnaires pourraient être
intéressés je pense que ce sera
extrêmement marginale car quand on rend
dans la fonction publique ce n'est pas
pour devenir chef d'entreprise ont pu
changer de métier enfin nous ne sommes
pas aux états unis et la culture n'est
pas la même mais bon si après tout
certains envie de changer de métier et
se reconvertir ils sont tout-à-fait loin
chez les hauts fonctionnaires quitté le
public pour le privé on appelle sa
pantoufle est une pratique qui ne
seraient que marginale maxime baffert et
énarque après quatre ans comme haut
fonctionnaire au ministère des finances
il s'est reconverti il travaille depuis
six mois dans cette grande entreprise de
communications
moi je pense que globalement tout ce qui
contribue à dynamiser la gestion des
ressources humaines dans
l'administration est une bonne chose est
vraiment une des raisons pour laquelle
je suis parti c'est parce que le système
était vraiment
vraiment en panne est extrêmement lourd
et presque sclérosé pour les syndicats
proposé de quitter la fonction publique
contre de l'argent ce serait une façon
de pousser les fonctionnaires dehors et
ce serait surtout prendre le problème à
l'envers
là le gouvernement est prêt à mettre
jusqu'à 24 mois de salaire sur la table
pour faire partir des agents alors même
qu'il refuse de rendre leur carrière
plus attractive pour la cgt le point le
sujet plutôt comment rentrer là car les
fonctionnaires plus attractives comme on
améliore d'un pouvoir d'achat leur
déroulement de carrière
le projet sera examiné au sénat à la fin
du mois incertitudes toujours cette
semaine sur l'avenir dure rsa le revenu
de solidarité active de martin hirsch
actuellement expérimenté dans plusieurs
départements ce dispositif coûte cher le
haut commissaire a l'estimé à environ 3
milliards si l'on si on l'étend à
l'ensemble des départements
mais selon lui il pourrait permettre de
passer à la trappe le seuil de pauvreté
alors s à savoir comment financer ce rsa
c'est un vrai casse tête en période de
disette flora sauvage un rsa a minima
c'est le scénario qui se profile pour le
revenu de solidarité active cher martin
hirsch le haut commissaire aux
solidarités actives
déjà expérimenté dans 34 départements
martin hirsch veut la généraliser en
2009 à la france entière ce qui
coûterait entre 2 et 3 milliards d'euros
mais le gouvernement semble décidé à ne
mettre qu'un milliard sur la table ce
pas un échec c'était une sûrement une
déception pour tous ceux qui
s'intéressent d'ailleurs à la lutte
contre la pauvreté et l'exclusion on est
dans les coeurs et ça dans un stade
expérimental qui comporte donc l'un
freinage vraisemblable mais qui ne remet
pas en cause le principe même qui est
incontournable le principe de
l'incitation
la reprise d'une activité et d'une quand
on est en situation d'exclusion pour
l'opposition l'idée d'un revenu de
solidarité active a minima n'est pas
acceptable
si par exemple bouclier fiscal le fameux
bouclier fiscal en juillet dernier
n'avaient pas été abaissées pour le
budget suivant de 60% 50% et bien les
milliards qui sont nécessaires pour
mettre en place le rsa
aujourd'hui on les aurait or cet argent
a été rendu aux contribuables les plus
privilégiés et ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui bien ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin
ceux qui en sont dans la plus grande
difficulté est bien n'auront absolument
rien l'état aura-t-il les moyens de
mettre en oeuvre le rsa alors que les
caisses sont vides
la question reste ouverte alors
dominique paillé là aussi on navigue à
vue faut le faire ou non le rsa rien
n'est tranché
quand est ce qu'on va trancher une fois
pourquoi dites vous qu on navigue à vue
on est sur une base d'expérimentation
dans 27 départements du rsa ces
expérimentations ne concerne pas tout à
fait les mêmes périmètres elles ne sont
pas financés de la même manière d'abord
tirerons les conclusions qui s'imposent
de ces expériences deuxièmement
tranchant
tranchons un certain nombre de questions
qui restent en suspens et notamment
cette question que je viens de citer du
périmètre doit-on inclure la ppe
doit-on inclure les ss dans le rsa et
enfin à partir de là et en fonction bien
sûr de nos capacités financières
lorsque nous aurons déterminé quels sont
le ou les financeurs général lisons le
le président la république indique le
rsa serait fait mise en place et
généralisée il a donné une date 2009
je crois que l'essentiel c'est
d'attendre et de réfléchir à la
meilleure formule à mettre en place les
orientations entend continuer dans la
série la vie
économique et sociale de la majorité est
loin très loin d'être un long fleuve
tranquille mercredi le très calme et
pondéré président socialiste de la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
didier migaud s'est offert une attaque
en règle contre le dispositif heures sup
du paquet fiscal dispositif voté je vous
le rappelle l'été dernier par la
majorité
un rapport s'appuyant sur un groupe
d'experts qui démontre l'inefficacité du
dispositif
un rapport qui a d'ailleurs fait la une
du journal le monde mercredi une brandi
jusque dans l'hémicycle par toute
l'opposition est l'occasion vous allez
l'entendre d'une très jolie passe
d'armes entre didier migaud et la
ministre de l'économie christine lagarde
on regarde on madame la ministre je suis
prêt à un débat contradictoire avec vous
quand vous voulez
la question n'est pas que ça plaise ou
non la question est également non plus
de ne pas affirmer mais de prouver de
démontrer et on ne peut pas vouloir une
évaluation systématique des politiques
publiques sans également s'interroger
sur l'efficacité des dépenses fiscales
que vous avez fait voter par le
parlement en juin dernier avant de crier
à l'inefficacité par journal du soir
interposés bien sûr demandons donc aux
salariés qui bénéficient des heures
supplémentaires qui bénéficient des 5
milliards d'euros que nous avons injecté
dans l'économie
s'ils ne sont pas contents de pouvoir en
bénéficier
parce que 5 millions d'euros c'est tout
simplement plus d'emplois plus de
travail plus de salaire et plus de
pouvoir d'achat alors ce paquet fiscal
dominique paillet désormais la cible
préférée des socialistes c'est une crop
lourde que vous allez porter jusqu'à
prendre que nous avons commis une erreur
c'est qu'au moment du paquet fiscal nous
n'avons pas su expliquer le bien fondé
de ces mesures pour relancer la
consommation augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat maintenir l'activité danse
bancaires ont le feu mais bien
évidemment comme d'habitude et de
manière simpliste le parti socialiste a
cherché le slogan le plus démagogiques
c'est vous fait des cadeaux aux riches
souvenez vous c'était attention la tva
sociale doit être mise en place
où on vous prépare un plan de rigueur
c'est classique
les socialistes ne propose rien mais il
assène un certain nombre de slogans
hambourg au bout du compte les français
à mon sens ne sont pas dus
parce qu'ils sont intelligents en
l'occurrence élémentaires en
l'occurrence de choses ce que dit didier
migaud
ce sur quoi il se fonde ses les trois
premiers mois suivant les mesures votées
par le parlement c'était avant qu'elle
ne rentre réellement en oeuvre
aujourd'hui que constate-t-on 26 % des
salariés bénéficient des heures
supplémentaires et 28 % d'heures
supplémentaires complémentaires si je
puis dire par rapport à ce qui existait
avant ait ont été réalisés grâce à ses
mesures de juillet dernier par
conséquence est une réussite ça
tellement qui nous a permis c'est une
réussite qui nous a permis de maintenir
un niveau de consommation dans ce pays
et donc de soutenir la croissance
à une hauteur bien supérieure à celle
qu'on constate dans les autres pays
d'europe
pour moi c'est une réussite ne sommes
pas encore en vitesse de croisière
nous y allons progressivement regardez
les chiffres de l'emploi jamais ils
n'ont été aussi bas
c'est une preuve par la démonstration
par les fêtes comme dirait didier migaud
que ces mesures étaient de bonnes
mesures
en face maintenant à la journée de jeudi
où il est encore question de la majorité
bien sûr et oui après l'échec des
élections municipales la majorité se
réorganise une première réunion a eu
lieu cette semaine au tour du président
de la république pour instaurer des
comités de liaison entre l'ump et ses
alliés les centristes approuve tout en
réaffirmant leur indépendance et pour la
première fois
michel mercier le président du groupe
centriste au sénat et bien été autour de
la table à l'elysée jusque là il était
fidèle à françois bayrou maintenant le
sénateur se démarque sans pour autant
rejoindre le nouveau centre
bref au centre rien n'est très simple ni
très clair nicolas béart la majorité
veut se renforcer au centre le comité de
liaison mise en place par le chef de
l'état doit consolider les liens entre
l'ump et ses alliés historiques avec au
premier rang le nouveau centre d'hervé
morin
nous voulons faire en sorte à travers ce
comité de liaison qu'il puisse y avoir
un débat en amont et qu'au lieu d'être
dans la réaction nous puissions et dans
la construction et dans une construction
qui nous permettent de prendre les
choses en amont
aujourd'hui le président
mais que nous propose un comité de
liaison qui respectera l'autonomie de
chacun dans ces conditions nous disons
oui
un rapprochement qui pourrait être utile
à l'ump dans la perspective des
européennes de 2009 et des régionales de
l'opportunité n'a pas échappé à certains
parlementaires du centre
beaucoup prennent leurs distances avec
françois bayrou michel mercier président
du groupe centriste au sénat déjà
participé à la première réunion du
comité de liaison
une participation qui présage de
prochain ralliement le pense ou des
sénateurs de l'union centriste
certains d'entre eux ont nous rejoindre
certains nous ont déjà rejoints et le
mouvement va se poursuivre assurément
selon une note publiée par le monde un
tiers des 30 sénateurs idf serait prêt à
rejoindre le nouveau centre
d'après hervé morin ces adhésions
interviendront avant le congrès
fondateur des 16 et 17 mai 2007 note de
l'elysée elle vous a été attribué dans
cet article je du monde dans la
stratégie comme l'elysée contre françois
bayrou il reste l'homme à abattre à
droite
écoutez d'abord sur cette note je ne
vais pas écrite je l' ai déjà dit et je
ne sais même pas si elle existe en tout
cas s'ils existent je ne les ai pas lu
je n'en ai pas été des synergies entre
bayonne et non écoutez franchement le
monde devient de plus en plus et je le
regrette un journal comme disait coluche
a emballé le poisson il n'y a pas une
information qui ne puisse être démenti
on l'a vu au cours de ces derniers jours
et ces dernières semaines donc
jacqueline le rédacteur en chef à faire
un peu attention à ce qu'ils écrivent
ces journalistes de manière à ce qu'il
ne trompe pas ces lecteurs françois
bayrou n'est pas un homme à abattre
il se lève tous les matins en se tirant
une balle dans le pied ça n'est pas
notre problème c'est le sien nous nous
avons une majorité qui est plurielle
elle est plurielle ou pluraliste avec
des gens qui représentent le centre et
de manière très diverse des sénateurs de
l'union du centre un parti le nouveau
centre
il ya même des gens qui sont des
sarkozystes de gauche à travers la
gauche moderne de notre ami bockel ou
avec les progressistes la prochaine
élection de se rassembler dans la liste
commune écouter tout ce que souhaite le
président de la république en mettant en
place ce comité de liaison c'est qu'il y
ait une harmonisation des positions
chacun ayant bien évidemment sa
sensibilité à faire valoir
c'est je crois une bonne préparation des
futures échéances
et c'est de bonne politique michel
mercier aujourd'hui il se situe où il
appartient à la majorité
dans un gîte et le modem michel mercier
n'a jamais fait défaut à la majorité
présidentielle
senna ou dans son comportement en rhône
alpes
c'est à lui à voir ce qu'il doit faire à
vrai dire quitté le modem le modem
disparaît je ne vois pas où est le
problème michel mercier peut rester
lui-même
voilà j on passe à un autre sujet
toujours jeudi on quitte un peu ce qui
ressemble à de la politique politicienne
et partisane et on retrouve les rues
parisiennes avec cette forte
mobilisation du mouvement lycéen jeudi
qui en est à son cinquième jour et
compte désormais entre 19000 et 35000
personnes dans les cortèges
des cortèges qui protestent contre les
quelques 11 mille suppressions de postes
prévues à la rentrée prochaine
tu avais darcos lui il reste ferme il
considère qu'il faut réformer le lycée
et que ce ne sont pas quelques postes en
plus ou en moins qui vont changer la
donne
de quoi mobiliser à la gauche bien sûr
jeudi quelques parlementaires
socialistes se sont rendus dans un lycée
parisien du 12e arrondissement à paul
valéry située dans la circonscription de
sandrine mazetier la députée ps
elle comprend la colère des lycéens et
les couteaux chase hall valérie a perdu
30 % d'heures d'enseignement depuis
depuis la rentrée 2002 c'est des adultes
en moins c'est des options - ce sont des
classes surchargées et en plus paul
valéry
à des résultats qui sont en deçà de la
moyenne parisienne et de la moyenne
nationale au brevet des collèges comme
au baccalauréat donc pâle valérie
mériterait des efforts de la part du
ministère de la part du rectorat
or paul valéry et massacrés dans sa
dotation horaire globale à la rentrée
prochaine comme de très nombreux
établissements de l'est parisien
comment vous allez réforme et dominique
paillé si vous en prenez au service
public préféré des français xavier
darcos a déjà expliqué ces réformes ce
que je veux dire simplement pour que les
français souhaite éclairer nous
dépensons 25% de plus que nos
partenaires pour l'éducation avec des
résultats qui sont très très moyen dans
l'échelle des résultats européens pris
pays par pays
ça doit nous interpeller quelques pas à
les autres service public préféré des
français les hôpitaux
gérard larcher a remis jeudi matin au
chef de l'état son rapport sur l'hôpital
il propose notamment de regrouper les
structures hospitalières et d'améliorer
les urgences des mesures qui vont
nourrir la future loi sur l'organisation
des soins mais des mesures qui
inquiètent aussi les élus locaux et le
personnel hospitalier
ils redoutent tous des fermetures de
services je propose tout de suite de
regarder les grands lignes de ce rapport
larcher avec flora sauvage premier volet
du rapport larcher sur l'hôpital
l'élaboration d'un nouveau paysage
hospitalier
il existe en france plus de 1000
hôpitaux publics un record en europe
l'idée de gérard larcher est de
travailler sur la notion de territoire
de santé avec la création de communautés
hospitalières
le sénateur ump préconise de regrouper
sur un secteur un grand hôpital de
pointe et des petits hôpitaux qui se
spécialiseront le but étant de
mutualiser les forces et d'éviter les
doubles au deuxième volet la gouvernance
de l'hôpital avec le renforcement des
responsabilités des directeurs
d'établissements troisième volet le
rapprochement avec le privé
les cliniques seront incités à assurer
des missions de service public comme
l'accueil des patients les plus démunis
aujourd'hui l'hôpital public doit faire
face à la concurrence accrue des
cliniques privées à les ultimes journées
avec celle de vendredi est aussi une
ultime cacophonie
ultime cacophonie je disais celle autour
de la carte de famille nombreuse dans le
cadre de la fameuse révision générale
des politiques publiques la rgpp l'état
semblerait vouloir cesser de financer ce
dispositif anciens de réduction sauf que
sauf que à droite tout le monde cette
semaine n'a pas vraiment tenu le même
discours face à la levée de boucliers
qu'a provoqué cette annonce pas mal de
propos contradictoires notamment entre
les ministres borloo et bussereau ainsi
qu'avec le président accoyer depuis
quelques heures enfin le discours semble
à peu près clair c'est bel et bien à la
sncf de prendre le relais financier de
ce dispositif c'est en tout cas ce qu'a
expliqué très clairement la secrétaire
d'état à la famille nadine morano en
écoute
l'état ne donne pas chouette ne plus
être 70 millions dans les têtes de la
sncf ou la carte famille nombreuse mais
elle souhaite que cette famille
nombreuse perdure et donc sur le
financement sur le financement
faut voir aussi comment une entreprise
telle que la sncf est une entreprise par
exemple ou réfléchir à nous proposer des
produits à destination des familles
alors dominique paillé l'état ne
privilégie plus les familles l'état se
désengage comment vous allez convaincre
à l'opinion du contrat
c'est encore de la désinformation c'est
la cacophonie gouvernementale sur ces
civils et le comme vous le souhaitez
mais il y a une réalité la carte famille
nombreuse perdurera et les avantages qui
sont attachés aussi ce que nous avons
dit très simplement et à l'ump nous y
tenons c'est que le financement soit le
plus juste possible quand la sncf fait
des milliards de déficit c'est le
contribuable qui paye quand elle fait
des milliards
elle en a fait un de d'excédent il est
logique qu'elle puisse a traversé la
prendre en charge une partie des
politiques qui font partie de son cahier
des charges en 2010 il y aura
l'ouverture à la concurrence et bien
évidemment si d'autres que la sncf
viennent sur le réseau ferré français et
répondent au cahier des charges est
inclus
cette dimension là ils seront plus
performants que la sncf fasse très
attention à ne pas perdre de parts de
marché en asie les meilleurs viennent
les familles n'ont rien à craindre et
donc je tiens à le souligner aujourd'hui
l'ump pour sa part a été clair nous ne
voulons pas qu'il y ait une remise en
cause de ces avantages sociaux et il n'y
en aura
l'état ne s'en mêlera plus ça ressemble
quand même à lui des engagements mais
non ça fait partie du cahier des charges
la sncf que d'assurer par exemple aux
familles nombreuses des tarifs
préférentiels qui sont justifiés ont
fait quatre familles nombreuses me
donnait maxi qu'à des réductions et l on
peut discuter d'un certain nombre de
choses je lis pas assume je vous parle
de la sncf
il était logique que pour cette
redistribution de revenus à travers
cette carte
quand la sncf était en difficulté il y
est une aide du contribuable parce que
nous vous y méprenez pas c'est le
contribuable qui payait aujourd'hui la
sncf fait des excédents il nous en
sommes très heureux
il est normal qu'elle assume l'ensemble
de ce qui figure dans son cahier des
charges
c'est une concession de service à lille
garde encore un tout petit peu de
temps pour terminer la semaine avec la
petite affaire ségolène royal que l'ump
a visiblement l'intention d'exploiter au
maximum a pas une petite affaire madame
royal se fait condamner par deux fois
pour non respect de la législation sur
le travail
employé au noir à certain nombre de ses
collaborateurs savent où un grand nombre
de patrons français de se faire taper
sur les doigts
madame royal en plus donne des leçons en
permanence de gestion sociale elle est
celle qui s'est fait ou a essayé de se
faire passer pour la meilleure porte
parole des salariés et des employés
exploité par les affreux patron elle
nous donne aujourd'hui l'image de ce
qu'elle est vraiment moi je crois que
c'est l'été tout à fait cohérente elle
démissionnerait de ses fonctions pour ne
pas avoir à continuer à supporter de se
regarder devant la glace et d'être pas
de président est d'alger et d'être l'
inverse de ce qu elle prétend être
devant le public et donc sa démission
écoutez je ne la demande pas je pense
que si elle avait un peu d'amour propre
elle l'aurait déjà fait vous aider la
région de la région vous espérez
réellement en cause écoutez madame royal
s'efforcera de d'effacer cet épisode
douloureux pour elle
encore que je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle
ait vraiment un coeur pour se rendre
compte qu'il est vraiment douloureux et
assez affamant merci dominique paillé
d'avoir répondu à ces différentes
questions sur l'actualité cette semaine
on attend donc bien une intervention de
nicolas sarkozy pour la semaine quad du
21 avril une clarification sur la
politique à venir des prochains mois
permettre cette intervention j'écoute
comme vous les médias on en parle je ne
peux pas vous confirmer de vous offrir
mais cette information très bien merci
on se retrouve bien sûr la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau parlement
hebdo avec au sénat notamment la
deuxième lecture sur le projet de loi
sur les ogm et à l'assemblée perry n'en
parlera modernisation de l'économie avec
l'examen du texte défendu par christine
lagarde et révision générale des
politiques publiques avec un grand débat
rgpp jeudi autant de sujets dont on
parlera effectivement dans la prochaine
émission le week-end prochain même
endroit même heure à la magie noire
non
bienvenue dans un monde de bulles de
céline sur un tag à l'acte est
entièrement dévoué dédié consacré au
neuvième art ça se discute la bande
dessinée débute pour moi je vis avec mes
personnes
moi je les dessine de tête
il ya même des choses incroyables ces
wonder woman c'est une envie depuis
longtemps de faire une sorte de super
héroïne coureurs à pied fait quelques
foulées
le tennisman envoie quelques balles tout
ça est passionnant bamoro de mon cerveau
donc je bouquine ce que j'ai été la
veille un micro merci c'est gentil un
bad et ça travaille ici hein je suis sur
les dernières pages un peu
l'effervescence au niveau des croquis
j'ai ici un peu que j'étais en
préparation or ce que je m'amuse quand
je sais c'est pas des choses qu'on a
l'habitude de voir tous les jours c'est
vraiment un découpage complètement
cinématographique un vrai régal pour
ceux qui aiment la bande dessinée